food and acne you've probably seen
hundreds of these sorts of videos and
infographics giving you all these foods
you need to stop eating to cure your
acne is there any truth to this are all
of these foods actually giving you acne
i'm michelle of lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd and cosmetic
chemist and today we're going to be
talking about the science behind food
and acne i've had so many requests for
this topic but obviously diet talk can
be very harmful so if you're trying to
avoid talk of diet and food this is
probably not going to be a good video
for you lots of dermatologists like my
friend dr anjali marto have seen some of
the damage that diet-based skincare
advice can cause she'll be giving us
some practical advice a bit later but
you've probably heard about the diet and
acne studies so we're going to talk
about them firstly there is zero doubt
that things you eat can potentially
impact your skin we get basically every
chemical our body needs from food apart
from like oxygen and skin is part of our
bodies but a lot happens in between
putting food in your mouth and
substances from that food affecting your
skin your digestive system breaks down
the food into its individual chemicals
some of that gets absorbed into your
blood your liver filters the chemicals
and transforms some of them and a whole
bunch get heated out of your body and
then some of the substances that end up
in your blood get taken up into your
skin which is about as far from your
blood as your body parts can get
or they might influence one thing in a
very long pathway that ends up affecting
your skin and there are a lot of other
things that can impact steps in this
process stress sleep hormones genetics
the skin care products you're using gut
bacteria medications and we know there
are tons of other things that affect
acne
acne is a very complex condition so it's
very possible that everything else has a
much larger impact that you can't
overcome just with tweaking your diet so
you are what you eat is technically true
but it isn't as straightforward as it
sounds it is incredibly tricky to work
out how specific foods in someone's diet
might eventually impact that specific
person's skin so science to the rescue
let's do some controlled experiments and
see what happens but it turns out that
studying how diet impacts someone's skin
is just straight up annoying in a
scientific experiment we ideally want to
change one thing at a time for a proper
test that way you can be somewhat
confident that the thing you change
caused the effect that you saw so let's
say we wanted to work out if chocolate
caused acne
here would be an example of a perfect
study we would get a good mix of people
probably a few thousand to make sure
that any effect we saw wasn't just a
fluke and we make them eat and do
everything the same
except you would give half of them
chocolate and that way you can compare
what happens with and without chocolate
you'd also want to make sure that no one
knows whether or not they're eating
chocolate and this is because of
expectation buyers if someone knew they
were eating chocolate and they expected
that to give them more pimples maybe
they would subtly change their other
habits or maybe they'd be stressed about
it and that could affect the outcome
same with whoever's assessing people's
skin and counting people's pimples maybe
if they expected that people eating
chocolate would get more pimples they
might change how they would count a
borderline bump whether or not that
would count as a pimple the two groups
would be using the exact same skin care
products have the exact same diet so the
same foods from the same brands apart
from the chocolate they'd eat food at
the same time they would drink the same
amount and types of alcohol they
wouldn't be allowed to smoke they would
sleep the same amount they would have
the same amount of stress and the same
exposure to things like sun and
pollution you'd want to keep the people
in specialized accommodation so they
couldn't like sneak out and get secret
midnight snacks you'd also want to run
the study for a good amount of time
because hormones and stress you want
that to be enough cycles that you could
get a good idea of whether it's the
chocolate or the stress or the hormones
causing any acne so probably at least
six months
anyway it turns out you're not allowed
to jail people for six months for
science even if you're paying them and
it turns out you have to pay them a lot
to convince people to let you control
every aspect of their lives
so this perfect setup never happens
nutrition studies have to make a lot of
compromises so it's a lot harder to be
confident in the results and because the
studies aren't really controlling all of
the variables a lot of other things can
affect the results so unsurprisingly a
lot of these studies have contradictory
results
so keeping in mind what our perfect
setup looks like let's have a look at
the two types of studies on food and
acne that we actually get the first type
are interventional studies where they
change people's diets and see what
happens
this sounds a bit like our ideal
situation except these studies usually
have less than 100 people often a lot
less we're talking an average of 30
something people in the trial that means
10 to 20 people in each group for
example 17 people getting chocolate and
17 not that is not a lot of people it's
really difficult to be confident there
wasn't some sort of fluke involved it's
quite possible that two people in the
chocolate group just happen to have
honking big pimples that week for some
other reason like it's exam week or it's
a particular point in their menstrual
cycle another issue with these studies
is that they usually don't tightly
control what the participants eat for
the chocolate studies usually they give
people a specific type and amount of
chocolate to eat but they don't tell
them what else they should be eating so
maybe having the chocolate meant they
didn't feel like eating as much fruit or
ice cream and it's actually the lack of
fruit or ice cream that's causing more
pimples a lot of these studies are also
on very specific groups of people for
example there are a lot of studies where
all of the participants are male 20
something college students in the us
most studies purposely use men because
these studies tend not to go for very
long because it's a lot cheaper that way
usually they're four weeks or less and
with women there's the menstrual cycle
and this has a massive effect on acne
the college students part is because
it's very easy to bribe college students
into doing a study so this very limited
group of people studied means that it's
difficult to see whether the results
would also apply to a woman in her
mid-30s like me or a teenage girl or a
male college student in japan we know
that genetics can have a really big role
in how people process food for example
lactose intolerance varies across
ethnicity and by country so generalizing
these studies which happens all of the
time on social media is a big problem
you'll see the results of these studies
turn into part of a cute infographic or
three seconds in a tik-tok video but
it's missing all of this extra context
three out of the four small studies on
chocolate published in the last 11 years
were done on just male college students
and there just aren't a lot of
interventional studies done on food and
acne a 2021 review looked at all of the
studies in the last 11 years and they
found 11 interventional studies that's
11 studies not just on chocolate and
acne but 11 interventional studies on
any dietary change in acne since 2009.
like i said good dietary studies are
expensive and complicated to run even
though these are still very far from
that ideal situation and even with all
of these compromises they're still rare
there is another type of study as well
that adds to what we know about food and
acne observational studies these look at
what people are already doing and try to
find patterns so for example do people
who eat more of a certain type of food
tend to have more acne there are more of
these studies because they're less of a
pain to run and they tend to have more
participants and more diverse
participants but they have a lot of
other issues because the people are just
going about their everyday lives as the
scientists record what they eat and how
their skin's going that means that
firstly there is a massive amount of
variation in what people are eating and
doing during the study there are a lot
of little things that could be impacting
the results that won't be recorded in
the study secondly there's a big issue
with recording what people ate and what
happened to their skin
in observational studies participants
usually have to tell the scientists what
they ate now if you know you have to
record your food it might change what
you eat and you might self-edit your
food diary a bit and if you've ever had
to record your food intake for whatever
reason you'll know how hard it is to
record every single thing you eat and if
you go to a restaurant or get takeaway
it is impossible to work out how much of
each ingredient you're eating i recently
had some random food allergies that i
haven't quite figured out yet and the
number of times i've told myself i'll
write it down later and then just
straight up forgot is ridiculous and a
lot of the time the studies don't get
people to record their food they get
them to fill out a survey afterwards the
problem here is that if it's already
hard to remember what you ate today it
is really really hard to remember what
you ate over the last two weeks
some of these food and acne studies got
people to remember what they ate years
ago the most highly cited study on dairy
and acne got their data by asking women
in their 30s and 40s what they ate when
they were teenagers and so all of these
issues make it harder to draw strong
conclusions about what food caused what
effect with these observational studies
let's take a look at a recent
observational study as an example
scientists got 24 and a half thousand
people in france to track what they ate
over three days at the start middle and
end of a year the people were also asked
whether or not they had acne and the
scientists found that there was a
statistically significant association
between current acne and eating fatty
and sugary foods sugary drinks and milk
so at face value it seems like this
study is saying that more sugar leads to
more acne but if we take a closer look
we have lots of people which is really
good the study used surveys for
recording food which has the usual
issues with imperfect recall and
self-editing there's also the fact that
most people don't eat the same thing
consistently over a week let alone a
year so these three day snapshots might
not reflect their usual diet and then
there's also that other data point the
acne out of the people who said they had
acne 44 diagnose themselves only 37 were
diagnosed by dermatologists and even
dermatologists get it wrong so it's very
possible that a lot of these people
didn't actually have acne it could be
something that looks similar like
folliculitis or rosacea on top of this
there are a lot of other factors that
could be messing up the results three
quarters of the people were female which
means there are lots of hormonal factors
that could skew the results for example
there's pcos which affects somewhere
around 10 of women of reproductive age
and this is strongly linked to acne
there's also hormonal contraceptives
which can increase or decrease acne and
roughly half of the women in france use
hormonal contraceptives eating more
sugary foods could also lead to people
eating less of other things like
vegetables and fruit and it might be the
fact that they're having less of these
things that could be leading to more
acne and not the sugary food itself
eating more sugar could also be a
reflection of something else that's the
actual root cause of the acne people who
eat less sugar might also be more health
conscious in the rest of their lives so
for example they might have a closer
relationship with their doctor they
might exercise more they might have a
less stressful lifestyle correlation
isn't necessarily causation the
association that the scientists found
between acne and these fatty and sugary
foods sugary drinks and milk was also
quite weak which means it's difficult to
say whether there would still be this
association if we took out some of these
extra factors
so with all of this background you can
hopefully appreciate how hard it is to
confidently say much about links between
food and acne and that's why dermatology
organizations are so careful in their
recommendations about changing your diet
to manage your acne the strongest links
that we have with this rather flawed
evidence are pretty weak associations
which means it's hard to say that eating
these foods actually cause the acne and
that stopping these foods will also stop
acne but these are the two things we
have the most evidence for firstly high
glycemic index and glycemic load diets
these have lots of refined sugar and
carbohydrates that absorb quickly into
your bloodstream and they seem to be the
strongest link there is between diet and
acne it's still a weak link out of the
three interventional studies on low gi
gl diets and acne two of them found a
relationship but one of them found no
significant difference in acne with high
and low gi
the second thing is dairy high intake of
dairy products seems to be associated
with acne this is a pretty confusing one
because dairy is a broad category and
different studies define it in different
ways it seems like low fat and skim milk
are more strongly linked to acne than
full fat dairy
yogurt and cheese don't seem to be
linked but whey protein does seem to be
linked with both high gi gl diets and
dairy the proposed ways that they could
be leading to acne are pretty similar
both of them can increase the levels of
igf-1 and insulin in blood higher igf-1
can increase androgen hormones
specifically the male hormones
testosterone and dht these can increase
the production of sebum which is the
natural oil in your skin that can clog
pores and increased sebum is one of the
contributors to acne higher igf-1 can
also lead to overgrowth of keratinocyte
cells in your skin which means you have
more stuff in your skin that can lead to
clogged pores both of these diets could
also lead to inflammation which is
another one of the contributors to acne
unfortunately all of this extra context
doesn't really make for a great viral
tic toc video
so how can we use this information the
science on the link between food and
acne is really not that solid which
isn't that different from a lot of
things in skincare there are a lot of
gray areas but the difference between
skin care and food is that adding or
removing a skincare product generally
isn't a big deal changing your diet is a
much bigger deal especially when it
comes to the two types of food we have
the most evidence for dietary changes
can affect a lot more than just your
skin
high gi foods and dairy are lots of
common foods so being very black and
white and restricting yourself to a
fraction of the foods you used to eat
can easily lead to nutritional
deficiencies and a wildly unbalanced
diet
and more importantly it can have a
massive impact on your mental health as
well in particular with disordered
eating for example you've probably heard
of orthorexia which is essentially an
unhealthy obsession with eating the
correct foods one of the first published
case studies on orthorexia was a woman
whose disordered eating started when she
started cutting out fat from her diet to
control her acne and there are lots of
examples in the literature and around
the internet where people who changed
their diets to try to kill their acne
ended up triggering an eating disorder
or making one worse it's not uncommon on
skincare forums to see people talking
about what foods they can't eat or how
hard it is to avoid these foods how
they're avoiding going out with their
friends to control their temptation how
much guilt they're feeling when they eat
one piece of the so-called wrong food so
with all of this in mind all the issues
with the evidence and the potential
dangers you want to be very cautious
when messing around with your diet to
try to clear your skin
the evidence is not robust enough at
this moment in time to recommend dietary
changes alone for the management of acne
the official recommendation is if you
notice a food that might be making your
acne worse try not eating it for a short
time and see what happens but if you do
want to change your diet to see if it
impacts your skin here are three tips
from dr anjali mato tip number one be
careful with bad swaps that might make
things worse there are a small select
group of people that may be sensitive to
dairy so if you do want to cut dairy out
of your diet and you want to switch to a
plant-based alternative
maybe rather than jumping from dairy to
oat milk which is a common swap that i
see people making
think about unsweetened soy or almond
milk instead
now the reason for that is oat milk has
actually got a very high glycemic index
tip number two if you drink whey protein
shakes see if you can use a different
protein source i think that's one
situation where people may benefit again
from switching to a plant-based protein
instead
particularly because the amount of cow's
milk protein that you effectively get in
a whey protein supplement is actually
quite significantly high we're not
talking about a little splash in your
coffee or a little bit in your porridge
and the third tip
think about maybe bringing in an expert
if you are genuinely thinking of
removing things from your diet you
should really do it in conjunction with
a professional dietitian
if you start removing lots of things you
may end up with essentially a diet that
is missing a lot of important nutrients
that you might need for your overall
general health which is obviously a
situation that we want to avoid and be
really careful when you're taking and
spreading simplified diet device there
can be very real harms involved so i see
a lot of patients that will cut out
huge food groups and usually it is dairy
gluten and sugar and if you look hard
enough if you cut those three things out
according to the internet you can fix
every skin condition going and it gets
to the point where their skin's not
getting any better they're getting
really anxious about the foods that they
can and can't eat and what ends up then
happening is people find themselves in a
situation where their diet becomes more
and more restrictive
there is more anxiety around food and
almost the development of disordered
eating patterns because you become so
paranoid that anything that you might
eat might trigger your acne so if
changing your diet isn't a great way to
try to fix your acne what might be a
better idea i think if you are going to
try and manage your acne at home before
you seek professional help i think
actually looking at your skin care
routine is a far better starting point
than starting to cut things out of your
diet now if you have changed your
skincare up you've been doing it for a
good four to six weeks but you're still
finding that your acne is not getting
any better
or it's getting worse
or it's becoming more extensive so it's
not just affecting the face but it's
extending onto the neck the back the
chest the shoulders
if it's starting to scar or leave
permanent marking and about 20 of people
who have acne will get permanent
scarring
or if it's starting to affect your
mental health you know it's affecting
your day-to-day and your confidence
all of those then are signs that you
should then move on to professional help
you've done what you can at home and
you've given that a good bash
and unfortunately this makes for an even
worse tick tock video if you like this
video give it a thumbs up subscribe and
click the notification bell for more
videos like this probably with less
dancing thank you so much to dr anjali
mato for helping me out on this video
i've linked the full interview in the
description her insights are always
really level-headed her instagram is
absolutely fantastic as well definitely
one of my top recommendations for
dermatologists to follow